قرار وحيد بشان الازمه عموما في ميمار
اعتمده مجلس الامن الدولي بعد شهور من
المفاوضات الشاقه سعت الدول الغربيه
خلالها الى قرار تحت الفصل السابع وعارضت
ذلك روسيا والصين القرار لم يرقى الى
طموحات الرونديا وان طالب في مجمله
بمعالجه قضيتهم وتوفير الحمايه لهم وضمان
العوده للنازحين واللاجئين الذين فروا الى
دول اخرى بحثا عن الامان
كنا نريد قرارا تحت الفصل السابع وبنودا
تتعلق بفرض حظر على الجيش ومحاسبه من
ارتكبوا الفضائع وبشان الرهنجيا نحن بحاجه
الى منظومه قوانين جديده للمواطنه تستوعب
جميع افراد شعبنا
الزياره التي قام بها اعضاء مجلس الامن
لمخيمات الروهنجياار وبنغلاديش عام 2018
لم تغير شيئا رغم الوضع المروع الذي ازداد
سوءا بعد اطاحه الجيش الحكومه المنتخبه
الحكومه المنتخبه لم تفعل شيئا لمساعده
الروهي وكان ينبغي ان تتوقع انها التاليه
بعدهم لقد اشارت الامم المتحده الى اعمال
اباده جماعيه وجرائم ضد الانسانيه وهي
انتهاكات متواصله
الجمعيات العامه للامم المتحده تبنت
قرارات اكثر قوه بشان الرهنجيا لكنها غير
ملزمه حيث دعت الى فرض حظر السلاح على
الجيش والمحاسبه على الانتهاكات وبالقوه
ذاتها جاء التحركات مجلس حقوق الانسان
وتقاريره عندما
المطلوب هو الحمايه يحتاجون الى حمايتهم
كمدنيين ومواطنين في ميان مار وهذا لا
يحدث للاسف هناك نقص في الاهتمام بالمساله
على الرغم من تكرار اثارتها من جانبنا يجب
ان يكون هناك انخراط ومشاركه سياسيه من
الاخرين وهي ليست من اختصاصنا فنحن نبلغ
عن اوضاع حقوق الانسان ونرصدها ولكن هناك
حاجه الى انخراط اكبر من الدول الاعضاء في
الامم المتحده بما في ذلك دول المنطقه
وهناك نحو مليوني لاجئ من الرونديا خارج
بلادهم ومئات الاف النازحين في مخيمات
تشبهها منظمات حقوقيه بالسجود وتظل جهود
المنظمه الدوليه ووكالاتها مصبه على
الجانب الانساني وسط نقص في التمويل
القرارات والتحركات الصادره حتى الان عن
الامم المتحده لا تضمنوا تحقيق العداله
والمحاسبه عن الانتهاكات والفضائع
المرتكبه ضد الروهنجيا ولا توفير الحمايه
لهم ولحقوقهم وعلى راسها حق العوده لمن
نزحوا او شردوا خارج بلادهم
مراد هاشم الجزيره نيويورك